so you want to make a map well lucky for
you far cry 5 includes a robust set of
tools that will allow you to craft your
very own playground of destruction it
can be overwhelming at first but once
you get the hang of it you can lay down
the skeleton for a map in minutes
however if you are new to this feature
there are some practices that in most
cases you should avoid number one don't
be flat for [ __ ] sake
yes flat maps can work yes it can be a
pain to carve out terrain and yes you
can still make a flat map interesting
however when was the last time you took
a walk outside nature isn't flat just
adding some elevation can make a world
of difference make rolling hills dig
valleys mould rivers and don't forget to
use the smooth tool to even out the
rough edges if you don't want to morph
the terrain then use one of the presets
you can select at the beginning number 2
don't make it too big it's tempting to
make a huge map trust me I've been there
many times but big maps present a whole
new set of challenge the bigger the map
is the longer it's going to take to fill
that map with interesting things if you
do have the time to make a big map you
also need to consider your budget these
bars in the corner here you can only fit
so much inside your map for example
here's an empty map that I'm going to
cover with trees as you can see that
exhausted my budget fairly quickly I
would recommend starting small with your
map and growing outwards number 3 don't
forget boundaries this is typically one
of the last things I do when making a
map once you've figured out the size of
your map switch to the map limits tool
this will give players a death countdown
if they get a little too adventurous
number 4 don't be bland one thing that
separates the top rated maps from the
rest are that they have textures it's
super easy to add textures and it can
make a world of difference you can even
change the default texture to whatever
you want within seconds just click on
the grid texture hit change and pick
whatever you want
number five don't be an ass
difficulty is good no one wants a
cakewalk up a map unless you're trying
to grind for XP but spawning me and a
tiny pit filled with yetis or heavy
enemies is not fun try to ramp up
difficulty as the player progresses
through the map also don't cram your map
with 80-plus enemies and ask the player
to kill everyone there are exceptions to
this such as the map called Semper Fi
but for the most part be reasonable
number six don't make dumb enemies while
it's not the most intuitive set of tools
you do have some flexibility with enemy
AI you can give them things to do areas
to defend and places to go this is
something that can wait until the end
but if you are trying to make a map that
tells the story and feels alive it's
definitely an important step number
seven don't forget about environment the
environment tools are how you set the
mood of your map you can adjust time of
day wind force fog the backdrop and post
effects seriously this is what brings
your map to life in my opinion you can
turn a simple collection of trees into a
dark eerie forest with just a couple
sliders now as you know rules are meant
to be broken and I'm sure with some
digging you can find exceptions to these
rules however as you create your own
Maps these are some solid guidelines to
follow especially if you're just
starting out if you have any tips leave
them in the comments below and if you
have any questions feel free to hit me
up on Twitter thank you for watching
[Music]